foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
more Nazis at a table
well the same Nazis
just a different host
[Music]
Tim pool
wasn't listening yesterday when I said
look
if there is a Nazi at a table
and you go sit with that Nazi
you are in fact and you converse with
them have a discussion
about their anti-semitic views try to
you know make sense of it all
your Nazi now Tim Poole obviously tried
to not
engage in the Jewish Banks Jewish media
type talk he was terrified Tim poo is
terrified of saying Jewish media these
are people who are like you should be
able to say whatever you want to say
they're just words Tim Poole could even
say the words because he knows he
[ __ ] knows
he [ __ ] knows
now this is all really incredible
and the reason why is because the former
president of the United States
the criminal that is the Cheeto desk
Cuban honor
announced that he was running for
president
you remember this
you remember this is a couple weeks ago
everyone's freaking out
I said good [ __ ] them let them run let
him [ __ ] lose he's losing right now
I don't see him running the circuits
getting on all the the great shows that
are the right Wingers the alt-right
I don't see him making the [ __ ]
headlines I mean he's going too soon as
soon as Jack Smith
decides to indict
but here's the thing Kanye West his
presidential run this is really [ __ ]
stupid I can't even believe these words
have to come out of my [ __ ] mouth
it's so stupid
what who are the Republicans who is the
Republican Party Mike Lindell is going
to run
as yarn seat chair
I hope he [ __ ] wins
now there's a lot of people in this
country like oh my God this is not
horrible no it is not listen the
Republicans have been a clown show long
before Trump ever showed up I don't know
if you remember this
but back in 2010
2010. it's a long time ago especially in
politics
that [ __ ] scumbag turtle and scent in
the Senate Mitch McConnell got on TV and
said after they had won he had said our
number one goal are not this is during a
[ __ ] recession our number one goal is
to make sure Barack Obama is a one-term
president that was their entire [ __ ]
platform the entirety of it
and look where they are today
their party their leaders are Nick
Fuentes Milo yiannopoulos Kanye West
and Mike Lindell
that's where they're at
[ __ ] [ __ ] Steve banned into Donald Trump
they've been backseated at this point
why do you think Milo went over to
Kanye's side Milo's no fan of Kanye by
the way
and Nick Fuentes is no fan of black
people for sure if you've ever listened
to his [ __ ] show or clips of his
[ __ ] show but the guy isn't
but they don't care it's not about that
they don't give a [ __ ]
it's about advancing their fascist cause
every single time no matter what
rather they have to use projection or
not
they'll do it whatever it takes
whatever it takes
and they absolutely absolutely it I I
don't I can't even tell you
how how [ __ ]
ridiculous this sounds
but Kanye West has stolen
we haven't even finished certifying the
votes for the 2022 midterms
they that the [ __ ] Congress isn't
even seated yet until January and these
[ __ ] morons are running for president
in 2024
do you see how [ __ ] broken they are
now is the time to strike folks if you
want democracy there is no better time
in history than now
I'm telling you I know it feels like
that that we're on the ropes and fascism
is at the front door and it is it's here
if you haven't been on Twitter in the
past couple weeks holy [ __ ] you talk
about a bunch of goddamn Nazis
you want to go see some [ __ ] Nazis go
open your Twitter app I mean that is if
Apple and Google keeps it up on their
App Store
because elon's a [ __ ] idiot
he's doing the same thing to Twitter
that Nick Fuentes Kanye West Milo
yiannopoulos and Donald Trump are doing
to the Republican parties same [ __ ] same
[ __ ] [ __ ] same thing same
destroying it tearing it all down just
for the sake of tearing it down or I
just like Nazis better
than not
and I know I've said this word a lot the
last couple days but God damn it I've
been saying it for a year
the Republican Party are Nazis
not neo-nazis not white supremacists not
white nationalists they're [ __ ] Nazis
and they're showing us
they're showing us they're they're like
not even hiding it anymore
not even not even trying I mean
literally Temple
this [ __ ] chucklehead who's like ow
everyone should be able to say words
there should be no cancer culture you
can't not say words they're just words
you can't be scared of words
[ __ ] wouldn't say Jewish media
wouldn't say it wouldn't say it into a
microphone you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you have these [ __ ] on your
show you're sitting across the table
from them you know they're gonna say it
you know they're anti-semites you know
they're [ __ ] Nazis you know every
problem they have they blame on someone
else specifically Jewish people
you have him on your show and you're
terrified Tim pull you [ __ ] [ __ ] to
say Jewish
Jewish Media or Jewish Banks you God
damn [ __ ] coward
you are such a [ __ ] every single one
of these right wing [ __ ] fake ass
talkers are [ __ ] cowards and they're
[ __ ] frauds
I don't know if you know Tim Poole is
this [ __ ] got his got his bones
going and Reporting in Ferguson
during the Michael Brown incident
claims he used to be a leftist and now
he's a Centrist he's not a [ __ ]
Centrist he's a Nazi because he sits at
a table and talks and and and gives
Credence to Nazis
that it's not something that you do the
most that you do when you are within
spitting distance of a Nazi is step one
punch the Nazi
that's step one and it's really most the
time because they're so [ __ ] weak
that's all you need is step one
everyone was upset that YouTube
stream this video
I'm happy that YouTube streamed this
video
I'm happy
I I hope they leave it up
it's a sight to see
everyone should go watch this video that
Republican politics have have [ __ ]
swirled so far down into the toilet bowl
that you have Nazi turds like Fuentes
Milo yiannopoulos Kanye West and Tim
Poole sitting around just making
decisions
on what the narrative is going to be for
the Republican Party
think about that for a second
it's it's not it's not [ __ ] Talking
Heads in Washington Mitch McConnell's
pissed he can't control this
why do you think why do you think it is
it is
actually believable that Mike Lindell
could become the chairman of the
Republican National Committee
it's believable
if you'd have told me that two years ago
I laughed in your face I said you're so
[ __ ] full of [ __ ]
guy can't even keep his [ __ ] pillows
in Bed Bath and Beyond and Walmart
you think he's gonna be the chairman
yeah today you would believe that [ __ ]
it's a hundred percent believable today
that's how that's how far down the
toilet bowl they have swirled
and it's only gonna get worse folks this
is not gonna get better as they take
over the house here
Ah that's not going to be good for their
party it's just not
and we need to mock them every [ __ ]
step of the way all of it
we need to not let up
we cannot stop laughing at them
because of how [ __ ]
much of a losing party they really truly
are and it's going to be a sight to see
it looks like we're going to be able to
keep government open maybe till the
summer late summer
looks like that might happen
so we got that that Benchmark Sometime
Late next year
you know right before fall right before
school starts right for the holidays I'm
gonna shut down the government they're
gonna do it oh they're gonna do it
you goddamn right they're gonna do it
ain't no [ __ ] I don't care if Kevin
McCarthy is the speaker or someone else
I don't give a [ __ ] they're gonna shut
that [ __ ] down
they can't bring the votes
especially when you have a bunch of
Nazis yelling and screaming into
microphones
about you got to shut it down because of
the Jewish media Jewish Banks or some
some blaming something on on Jewish
people
because they're crazy
they're off their [ __ ] rockers the
rails are off the party
and they're about to crash this [ __ ]
now is not the time for safety measures
let them wreck this [ __ ]
because that's what they're gonna do
with this new Congress
they've already told the entire country
our number one our number one goal
is a laptop
that doesn't exist
we're gonna we're gonna make sure to
impeach Joe Biden because Hunter Baden
owned a laptop
good [ __ ] them try it dummies do it
do you have any idea how much fun it'll
be every single day for me to sit here
and mock these [ __ ] idiots
it'll be it'll be glorious ah it'll be
great entertainment
that's what they want they want our
government they want our country they
want our democracy to be [ __ ]
entertainment we are at the intersection
of WrestleMania in real life
what do you think [ __ ] Kanye running
around the country and people having to
pay attention to this dumb [ __ ]
for now that's the reason
why why do we have to talk about Kanye
the reason why is because the former
president United States
who is who is right now the most likely
nominee for their party
invited him and a bunch of Nazis to eat
dinner with him
are you not paying the [ __ ] attention
and not one not one goddamn prominent
Republican who supports Trump
says anything not a [ __ ] thing not a
God damn thing
and and the country's worried about
these people taking over politicize this
[ __ ] out of this you think you think
people in rule [ __ ] bum [ __ ]
wherever are are totally [ __ ] behind
Nazis Kanye West and Donald Trump run in
the country you people are out of your
[ __ ] minds
yeah Q Anon is a hell of a drug but I'm
telling you I'm telling you this is this
is the [ __ ] fade this is it
and we can't we can't just stand back
and watch them drive this [ __ ] into
the ditch
we gotta bring the ditch to him baby
let them ditch this [ __ ] [ __ ]
them it's been a long time coming with
this party they have no [ __ ] ideas no
[ __ ] policies
they complain about everything all they
can do is [ __ ] obstruct it doesn't
matter if it's in our [ __ ] Senate our
Congress our state governments our
County governments our [ __ ] school
boards that's all they know how to do is
obstruct
they can't do government because that's
what they do is obstruct which is not
government
so let them ditch this [ __ ] [ __ ]
them and this is a sign this is a sign
of the fade baby
oh man
and I'm excited I'm excited I hope Kanye
West Nick Fuentes and Milo yiannopoulos
keep on their National [ __ ] Nazi tour
hails to the yeah
and not one [ __ ] not one
[ __ ] says anything about it
where are you Mitch McConnell these are
the leaders of your party
Mitch McConnell you stupid [ __ ] these
are the leaders of your party this is
who is energizing your voters
Kevin McCarthy these are your people
these are the ones who are setting your
National narrative and your messaging
this is the Republican Party
rather you [ __ ] like it or not
rather Mitt Romney wants to admit it or
not
take the r off your name mitt
that's the only way you're gonna get out
of this
because I'm not gonna stop I'm not gonna
stop making you into Nazis
as long as you're sitting at tables and
dining with them talking to them trying
to figure out what their argument and
what their position is about the Jewish
media
and placating to Nazis
making sure not to hurt their feelings
[ __ ] you
you are you are going you are going to
be the America First Nazi party that is
what you're going to be and I am
hell-bent hell-bent on branding you that
way [ __ ] you may just take the name over
and Michael and Dale oh my God Mike
Lindell being the the chairman of the
Republican National Committee nothing
could be better
in my mind
for our democracy then that [ __ ]
chucklehead taking the reins at the
Republican Party
imagine
how quick I bet Mike Lindell could
destroy the Republican party faster than
Elon Musk destroyed Twitter
I almost bet money on it
and we're sitting around going oh this
is a bad thing Hills to the no it's a
good thing [ __ ] them they deserve it
they deserve Mike Lindell
they've earned him baby
they've earned him
they [ __ ] they played footsie with
that crazy son of a [ __ ] for the last
two years they've given him microphones
they've given him [ __ ] they've given
him [ __ ] money they've given him the
ability to amplify his [ __ ] lies and
his misinformation and his delusion
that [ __ ] crackhead
[ __ ] them let them have them and give it
to him
oh yeah real and raw baby let's do it
I mean there's people out there that
aren't fans of Jamie Harrison but can
you imagine
the competition between Jamie here and
Mike Lindell
think about that
listen to me in Arizona Katie Hopps not
the greatest candidate in the world I'll
say it she wasn't she wasn't the
greatest candidate she was the one that
was picked in the primary
for whatever reason she wouldn't debate
she wouldn't get in front of a
microphone some say it was a great
strategy it's not it's not a good
strategy not and she still beat the Mike
Lindell of Arizona
Katie Hobbs didn't win because she's a
great politician because she she ran a
great campaign it's because Carrie lake
is [ __ ] crazy
Mike Lindell style crazy folks
I my question is what can Democrats do
to organize to make sure that Mike
Lindell is the chairman of the
Republican National Committee at this
point is there a [ __ ] GoFundMe
somewhere do we have a Super PAC started
to make sure this crazy [ __ ] is in
charge of their party what the [ __ ] do
we gotta do
to put these [ __ ] nuttier than
squirrel turds people in charge of their
[ __ ]
nothing will topple it faster
Kevin McCarthy can't even get to 218.
because of this type of crazy
they just they just got their asses
stumped
in a midterm they were supposed to win
by 50 60 votes
in the house they were supposed to take
the [ __ ] Senate
we gained a seat
they didn't win one not [ __ ] one
swing state
in the governor's Secretary of States
and attorney general races
we kicked their [ __ ] ass and it ain't
because we're good
it's because they're [ __ ] Off Their
Rockers
and that's the kind of crazy they love
folks
so give them what they want give them
what they want
imagine two years from now when Gen Z
is a it's a way bigger voting block
all these delusional [ __ ] old people
who believe anything FOX News tells them
are [ __ ] dead
the electorate has changed in some of
these states
imagine the possibilities imagine the
possibilities of what kind of candidates
Democrats could absolutely win with and
God knows where
if Mike Lindell
is the actual chairman of their party
he's going to be running around talking
about [ __ ] voting machines
he will not stop talking about it
delusional Facebook Q Anon type [ __ ]
there's one thing that's clear from the
2022 midterm
and Arizona is the perfect example
Arizona is not a blue State I don't give
a [ __ ] if Arizona's blue then [ __ ]
Texas is blue
you got me it's not that definitive
Arizona didn't flip to Blue Arizona just
isn't about the [ __ ] crazy
you see it in the 2020 presidential
election where Mark Kelly won that that
special election and and Joe Biden
stomped Donald Trump's ass
you see it in this election
in this midterm where Kerry Lake fincham
and [ __ ] Blake Masters didn't have a
shot in hell
not a chance with that type of crazy
that's the perfect example folks this
country is sick and tired of the [ __ ]
nonsense
but they're not going to give up on the
nonsense they're not gonna do it
you can't kill an idea fascism will not
die
we can get it to go hiding underneath
the rock for another 30 40 years maybe
eventually
but it's going to take work
and it's not just gonna be winning
elections we have to continue with a
narrative and we have to continue to
pound the drum every single day
we cannot quit
did you see some of the video from
Maricopa County of these [ __ ]
whack-a-doos these Q Anon loons
just talking all this craziness
about the election
if that's not enough for you to go boy I
should really be talking about elections
every [ __ ] week with people I know
and I know it seems like God Tony every
week Jesus we got to talk about this for
two you're gonna have to talk about this
for a long longer time than two years if
you want fascism to go crawl back
underneath that [ __ ] rock
it's going to take a hell of a lot more
than a couple [ __ ] years
hell a lot more time than a couple years
we're gonna have to pound this drum for
decades
decades Decades of work
is what it is going to take for them to
crawl back underneath their Rock and and
mark my words as soon as we go well
we're satisfied now
not but two more decades it'll be back
out from underneath this rock ideas
don't die
they don't and weak people always blame
other people for their [ __ ] problems
always
and there's no there's no group of
people in this country that is weaker
than these trumped up white dudes
none of them there's not a group that's
weaker than a bunch of trumped up white
dudes bunch of [ __ ] snowflakes cry
baby whining little [ __ ]
I know I know him I know plenty of them
oh but my but but I'm supposed to have
it given to me
but but I don't have privilege but I
want it
but but I'm white and I'm a man I'm
supposed get the [ __ ] out of here they
are the weakest [ __ ] demographic in
this entire country the weakest why do
you think they're lashing out so much
and it's it's never been more clear
than Nick Fuentes Milo yiannopoulos and
Kanye West are now the leaders of the
Republican Party they're pushing they
are the leaders of the narrative and
Dick Fuentes has been the leader of this
narrative for a long time I've been
telling you that but this guy has been
driving their National messaging rather
anyone wants to admit it or not how do
you think [ __ ] Kanye West and all
these people grabbed onto this [ __ ] how
do you think [ __ ] Marjorie Taylor
green
keeps talking about the crazy [ __ ] she's
talking about this morning she's talking
about how farts she can't even
understand how farts work I'm not
[ __ ] you this is real she is
tweeting on her just recently
unsuspended Twitter account about how
farts work
she doesn't get it she didn't understand
how farts work maybe we'll go over that
today with Texas Paul I'm sure Texas
Paul knows how far it's worked
I'm sure Texas Paul knows how farts work
I cannot believe that we have to sit
here and talk about this [ __ ]
but this this is the Republican Party
this is who they are and we must mock
them just like today we're going to mock
them for being a bunch of [ __ ] Nazis
and we're gonna mock them for not
understanding how farts work everybody
you are the best audience in the entire
world and I do mean world because people
listen to this show all around the world
people who are pro-democracy everywhere
in all parts of this planet
and you are the best audience on the
planet
and we run on your support if you want
to give a tip go to tonymichaels.live go
to tonymichaels.live you have a one-time
temper you can set it up monthly we
appreciate any help you can give there
but more than anything we love having
you here on YouTube and in the chat I
know the mods love it we have the best
moderators in the world too so come to
YouTube subscribe to the YouTube channel
get in the chat
talk to the even if you even if you're a
hater come come hate cause we got haters
over on Facebook too happy Tony Michaels
just go follow us over there if you're
on Midas Touch page go follow me on my
page you'll be able to see fake Gabe's
comments I think he was banned from the
Midas Dutch page which is not surprising
he's he's edging on getting banned on
mine but you know
I need someone to set those softballs up
for me to hit out of the park every
single week and fake Gabe he never
disappoints with the Trump copy machine
also download every single episode this
is super important Go download every
single episode on your favorite
directory Apple Spotify Google make sure
to leave us a great review while you're
there
speaking of why you're there and while
it's here
Twitter go follow us at Tony Michaels
pod we are back this week with bonehead
of the week we will have the poll there
on Twitter as long as Apple
doesn't take it down from the App Store
I had an iPhone what the [ __ ] am I gonna
I'm gonna sit here on my computer with
Twitter get the [ __ ] out of here Elon is
such a dumb [ __ ] what an idiot and then
he
he's gonna go to war with apple yeah
okay I got it got it now you see why I
want Mike Lindell to run the Republican
National Committee oh God
same same thing Elon Mike Lindell same
[ __ ] it's the same thing let's do that
everyone stick around you know it's
Tuesday it's Taco Tuesday here on the
Tony Michaels podcast but also it's
Texas Paul Tuesday everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
good
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam gems skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
bomb
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show it's
Tuesday
Tuesday Tuesday Tuesday
you got Texas call with us I promise
We're not gonna do any beef jerky and
easy cheese [ __ ] today hails to the
known not safe I promise
so uh keep and keep tuned in the entire
day because we're not
how are you
I'm wonderful I got a little ladybug
followed me and I I'll be honest with
you I'm rarely if ever speechless but
but I I'm real I'm reading this tweet
um did you think I was lying I I thought
you were joking I really do I thought
nah
she's tweeting about how farts work
she's wondering she's crowdsourcing it
how do farts work
well actually she definitely does not
understand how farts work no she does
not understand I you know for someone
like Marjorie Taylor who
more than likely has done her share of
farting I don't know if you if you saw a
picture of her turkey from Thanksgiving
but God damn that that'd give you drier
than popcorn farts that goddamn I'm
telling you but here's the thing if
she's trying I know what she's trying to
do she's trying to be like oh liberals
wearing masks again which I I mean I'm
not really sure exactly where in the
country that Fox News was talking about
the other day they came in like breaking
news there's people wearing masks like
yeah a lot of people are [ __ ] sick
and when you're sick or you don't want
to get sick you wear a mask so it's less
likely that you'll get sick it's not
complicated these are not hard things to
understand we've been doing this for a
long time and they said on on Fox News
that they're stopping short of a mandate
which means there isn't one
and I just don't quite understand how
Marjorie Taylor green still hasn't
figured out how mask works but so so
much so that she has compared it to
farts and underwear
and she doesn't know how farts work it's
kind of ridiculous can you imagine the
stains in her underwear I mean
watch apparently she wears heavy cotton
underwear yeah extremely heavy cotton
underwear that's what you read right
extremely heavy extremely heavy is that
like pins right right yeah what do you
what am I supposed to do [ __ ] I I can't
let me pull it up I can't I can't stop
her from typing you have to be careful
with this line of humor because this
dumb [ __ ] is the kind of person that
would actually take a picture of her so
in her underwear just to prove she's not
wearing industrial strength cotton
underwear
and she may need industrial strength
here's this is the tweet this is her her
account that uh has been recently
unsuspended
um do you know that she has had her her
her official uh Congress account for
some time but this is her personal
account that was suspended
um some time ago when Twitter you know
actually suspended people for you know
spreading around hating lies
um she says so many people still wearing
masks which what the [ __ ] does she care
someone else is wearing a mask I don't
understand that then she goes on to say
I just want to ask you she's crowd
sourcing she's like hey not really sure
here here's what she asked here's the
question and it's got two question marks
on the end so it's an important one
if a pair of underwear really thick Ones
high quality cotton yeah really thick
high quality cotton
can't protect you from a fart I'm not
exactly okay she goes on then how will I
how will a mass protect you from covid
okay so I'm not sure if she's saying the
cotton underwear are supposed to catch
the fart coming from someone else or if
it's supposed to make sure you're not
[ __ ] on someone I'm not okay I can't
really you know you know that's exactly
what you're saying if you can smell my
fart and how the hell is a mask supposed
to help you
I mean for God's sakes when I hotboxed
you in the elevator the other day did
you feel real safe because I had some
thick ass anywhere on and you smell it
anyway
you know this may come from her hanging
out with Trump right like she likes to
hang out with Trump and I don't know
what
what adult diapers he wears it probably
depends but
if they're probably really thick and
even though even though he's got the
diapers on the [ __ ] catchers on you can
still smell him and that may be why
she's confused about how far and and the
thing is really honestly
farts and covet do not work the same way
farts are not viruses that is not even a
thing
but I got a video 1095 mask isn't a
stinky ass thick ass cotton pair of
Marjorie Trader greens underwear either
an n95 mask will stop a fart folks it
will
if nobody's had to tell you this the
reason when you walk around with an n95
mask on and you're not breathing in them
farts and you're near Marjorie Trader
green and you're not smelling farts it's
because you're masks it's your mask
so the n95 Texas Paul is confirming here
the science shows that it will stop a
fart um now I want to show you this is
backyard science this is backyard fart
science and our friend keep Troy blue
um posted this over on Tick Tock now he
posted this several [ __ ] months ago
okay
um now the the person who was commenting
asked him almost the exact same question
that Marjorie Taylor green is sourcing
here
oh yeah this is this is I got to tell
you man this has been hillbilly
knowledge for a long time man they
really do believe this
right well you mean since the pandemic
the whole fart underwear thing is that
what you're saying yeah yeah the mass
don't work because underwear don't stop
farts I mean that that
[ __ ] spread Nicks okay so here's
here's right here's here's the question
posed to Troy on Tic Tac this was months
ago but when I seen this tweet from
Marjory Taylor green I immediately
immediately remembered this video
now the person is asking Troy here
explain this underwear and jeans can't
stop a fart from traveling
how would a mask stop a virus let let
Troy explain it to you well it's
official I've lost all faith in humanity
and those of you that have been
following me for a while know that this
is Quite a feat considering the sheer
dumb [ __ ] that I've had to put up
with over the last two years on this app
this one particularly sent me over the
edge and so here I am standing in my
backyard at night addressing farts to a
complete stranger on the [ __ ]
internet so let me try to lay this out
for you in a way that you're clearly
like eight-year-old mind might be able
to understand not all microscopic
particles that you can't see with your
eye are exactly the same size for
example uh gas particles Like Oxygen are
a hell of a lot smaller than viruses
that's why you're still able to breathe
when you're wearing the mask because the
microscopic holes in The Mask are large
enough for oxygen particles to get
through even though they are able to
stop the coronavirus same principle is
true generally when wearing under
underwear and jeans when you fart what
you're smelling when somebody farts is
the methane gas coming off of the fecal
matter not the fecal matter itself the
methane gas is able to make it through
the underwear and the jeans even though
the underwear and the jeans are stopping
the fecal matter do a little experiment
for me okay
the next time you're with one of your
frat brothers and they tell you they
have to fart put your face right up next
to their ass twice okay this is an
experiment we have to do it a couple of
different ways to prove that it works
put your face right up next to their ass
one time while they're wearing jeans and
underwear and the next time when they're
butt ass naked and their bare ass is
right in front of your face then have
them fart on your face see what happens
uh biologically
see the difference between the time when
they fart on you with jeans on and when
they fart on you with bare ass chances
are one of those two times you're gonna
get a pink eye and it won't be the time
when they're wearing jeans now the fact
that I had to just spend this time
explaining farts to you and I'm going to
publish this on the internet
um really makes me want to go cry in the
shower for about a week so
congratulations if that was your
ultimate goal in the meantime how about
you enjoy the next few days of your life
and how my followers are going to
respond to you for making me do this and
just remember that you ask me three
times literally three times to make
oh boy I mean you just can't um now I
posted this you know normally people
would screenshot the uh the tweet from
Marjorie Taylor green I saw that a lot
you know they where they screenshot it
and then post it on their page I
actually quote tweeted with this video
for Marjorie Taylor green the reason why
I thought it was a public service
because I really thought she was asking
the question Texas well I really thought
she wanted to know so I wanted to make
sure if she wanted to do the experiment
that Troy's talking about here she had
the opportunity
yeah and while we're talking about it
you know he hits it right on the head
but he's off just a little bit just a
little bit
you know your genes will stop the fecal
matter to a point not all of it most of
it I mean you pressure you pressurize
fecal matter coming at you and that's
what people don't understand about farts
is they're never completely dry okay
they're not they're not ever completely
dry even if you think they are I mean
you're like you know you let one go and
you're like whoo okay that one was dry
not completely right okay you just blue
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you did that when you
must ask you [ __ ] and you're riches
that's the way it is
now an n95 Master you got to understand
there's distance between the ass and the
face right there is okay so that methane
you know you're not breathing in fecal
matter
even even though it may spring the jeans
a little bit right this is why they tell
you to cover your your toothbrushes
folks I mean [ __ ] flies okay it does and
small in small enough particles it flies
okay now I want you to think about the
difference between Marjorie Trader Green
in an elevator with you busting ass
blowing that dry ass turkey all over
that elevator
it's not just methane folks there are
actually particulates to get through the
[ __ ] industrial cotton underwear
better would you feel in that situation
if you had an n95 mask on
a
respirator mask or we're just there just
breathing that [ __ ] in your lungs
literally
I mean let's just be clear about it I I
guess after her question that was posed
on Twitter this morning that most of her
colleagues in Congress and maybe even
her staff will um will when they get
into an elevator they'll make sure to
have a full respirator
um not just an n95 but a full respirator
you may need that with her apparently
she has problems with farting through
her very high quality thick cotton
underwear this is crazy industrial
underwear yeah this is this is
absolutely Texas Paul
this person that posed this question
that we're talking about that we have
this conversation yeah it's funny it's
great this person
is actually trying to swing the vote in
our Congress
let me say that again
elected to a congressional seat
trying to use
you her influence inside her this the
the [ __ ] crazy caucus to try to swing
the vote to Kevin McCarthy like this is
literally someone who has influence in
the Republican caucus in the Congress
trying to make sure that they get the
speaker that they want this is [ __ ]
Insanity that this is the Republican
party but this is them this is who they
are yeah you know I mean it's like the
voters sent a very clear message this
election extremely clear enough of the
[ __ ] I mean it was a really short
sweet message from the voter to the
Republican Party
enough of the [ __ ] you know Arizona
is not a deeply liberal State now folks
don't confuse yourself don't try to pass
a really liberal agenda in [ __ ]
Arizona right now don't do it because
they didn't become liberals what they
the message they sent was
sick of this [ __ ] right just be
grown-ups
what are the what do the Republicans do
hold my bear you know double down on the
[ __ ] stupid let's talk about hunter's
laptop yeah that's what the people want
you know all they're thinking is all
those [ __ ] hearings the hearings they
had over Benghazi
worked for them
that's all they're thinking
is is the Benghazi hearings worked for
them
and they think they're going to do it
again they think they're just going to
hold a spectacle and people are all of a
sudden just gonna
you know
Benghazi 2.0 and it's not going to
happen
people have changed people are tired of
that [ __ ] we've lived with them for
years
and people are sick of hearing it and I
really have
a really a question just seared into my
mind right now that I can't get out do
those industrial underwear still have
the little bow in the front
you know I'm not really sure I don't I
don't know I can somebody in the other
ladies did the big thick industrial
granny panties still have the bow in the
front
oh I don't know maybe you should
crowdsource it on Twitter apparently
that's where you go ask about underwear
problems is Twitter I'm not sure
speaking of underwear problems uh this
guy looks like he has a few now you're
talking about Crazy in Arizona there's
several clips of of these Cuban honors
uh getting up before the Board of
Supervisors in Maricopa County right
um now what what happened yesterday is
the the Board of Supervisors who is run
by a republican by the way in Maricopa
County went to certify the vote
yesterday now what they did is they
allowed
these nut bags two minutes to say
whatever the hell was in their nutty
little
[ __ ] you know mind
whatever they wanted to say full two
minutes and each one of them got two
minutes now once they got done with the
two minutes what the Board of
Supervisors did is did a presentation on
the vote the count and how it's all
certified or it can be certified it's
legitimate it was safe it was fair it
was free election they go through it
right but none of these people stayed
for that part they all came in said
they're crazy ass nutty [ __ ] and then
they left they didn't want to hear the
truth but here is here's one clip
and this guy claims to be an attorney I
guess or a prosecutor I don't know this
guy's a [ __ ] nutcase let's listen
slave
that's what I am to this system to your
corruption
this is outrageous
this is a national crisis and you're
giving people two minutes to address a
national crisis and the way that you
guys can just sit there it's disgusting
watching you pledge allegiance to my
flag was disgusting the way that you
sold us out
you said you don't have the statutory
Authority
to do anything
you're going to take a yes no vote
what does that tell us yes or no if it's
just yes then why are you here
why are you here then you have
discretion and when you certify
something you're saying that it's
trustworthy there's nothing trustworthy
about this
this is theater it's Optics
I was a long time prosecutor I went
after drug traffickers this is vote
trafficking at its finest I've seen the
criminal element you are vote
traffickers you are boat trafficker
Criminal
what are you going to do about it you've
sold us out
you sold us out you've sold us out
so we're not here to be civil
you're worried about language
we're worried about our voices being
stolen and never getting a fair election
again that's what we're worried about
okay I'll stop there Gabe Sanchez to me
this sounds like welcome back by the way
um it sounds like to me that this guy
when he says we'll never have a free and
fair election again what he means is is
Republicans and the crazies the Q anonas
may never win an election again I think
that's what he's saying what do you
think yeah I mean it really is the uh if
we aren't allowed to cheat then how are
we supposed to win anymore guys like
that's what it is they're getting upset
if they're like whoa whoa hold on hold
on if we're making it actually free and
fair for everyone
then that means that our party won't
have a chance anymore right because all
they'll be able to rely on is
gerrymandering or other means of voter
suppression but when it comes to just
counting the votes as they were you know
voted on
or tallied they're they're like oh well
that's how you count that's that's not a
that's not at all how we would count the
ballots we got to make sure it's just
like shut the [ __ ] up oh he does a whole
thing I'm gonna get back to it on the
ballots thing but Texas Paul this is the
type of [ __ ] you're talking about
because this crazy loon he's not going
anywhere he's not going to stop talking
his crazy ass [ __ ] there's not going to
be stopping this game from saying crazy
[ __ ] and trying to push crazy ideas
and think about think about how [ __ ]
arrogant he is okay in his mind there's
no possible way that people didn't like
him
that people didn't like the [ __ ] he
stood for
he cannot wrap his around mind around
the very concept that is democracy that
people took a look at the [ __ ] this guy
was offering
and said no no we no we don't want that
we're going to go over here
and if he can't wrap his head around
that and they're telling us point blank
to our face this guy's telling you
we will not change to win your vote
we're not going to do it we're not going
to change to win your vote we realized
you know
we're just going to say we didn't lose
I mean that's Insanity man that is
insanity to the nth degree to think that
you entered into a contest an election
and you think that there's no way you
possibly lost that that people didn't
look at you and say you're [ __ ] crazy
and vote the other way
I mean
they're I mean they're just telling us
this will be a fight we will have for
decades for [ __ ] decades we literally
need to stop this party into a mud hole
hold its face into the goddamn tepid
water until it quits breathing because
they're telling you they're not going to
participate in goddamn democracy they're
not going to try to win anybody's vote
anywhere
they're going to try to bully their way
into office
well I mean and that's and that's their
that's their tactic is intimidation
right I mean that's what they're doing
in these two I mean the the same and the
quick just kind of like tangent here is
it the same type of people who complain
about oh oh this is you know uh it was
rigged because people didn't agree with
what I had to say are the same people
like I don't know Elon Musk and other
you know Free Speech free market
capitalists who want a [ __ ] and moan
and complain because a company even
though the claim was debunked and people
were like oh here's an Apple ad right
here people like Elon Musk want to say
oh because they don't want to pay
Twitter to post ads onto Twitter
that is somehow an attack on Free Speech
that's a private company it's a it's a
company that made their own decision on
how they wanted to use their own funds
and the same way with a voter if they
don't like what you're offering and they
don't like the platform you're running
on then they can say hey you know what
look I may not like this other guy that
I'm voting for but I sure as hell don't
like what you got going on right and
that's why a lot of people are like
during the 2020 election or even during
the midterms you were like whoa how what
where did all these Biden voters come
from where did all these like Democratic
voters like look they don't have to
completely agree with their line of
thinking and their politics and policies
but they 100 percent looked at the
candidate
on the Republican side that was a
trump-backed candidate or looked at
Trump during the 2020 election and said
look I mean if my vote's got to go
somewhere it's not going for these
[ __ ] heads
well I mean that's that's the story here
because here let's listen to some more
crazy from this um
former prosecutor I guess Criminal
you've sold us out
you sold us out you've sold us out
so we're not here to be civil
you're worried about language
we're worried about our voices being
stolen and never getting a fair election
again that's what we're worried about
so a curse upon you a curse upon all of
you you smug smug people
what you gotta you gotta
another chicken for him and he's burned
down Mr Hickman
[Music]
chairman
all right am I bothering you because
this election bothered me
and you're doing nothing about it I
don't care about that stupid buzzer
this is sickening you have the power as
the chairperson to enlarge the time
limits and actually hear your
constituents
they're putting a muzzle on them
thank you right your time is up
why would anyone want to sit and listen
to more of this nonsense I don't even
want to play it on this show but what
the hell am I supposed to do you say I
got I gotta expose you [ __ ] idiots
for what you are
speaking they're exposing idiots because
I'd love to sit and listen there's like
I don't know there's probably about 12
of these clips
you know these uh it's just batshit
crazy yeah um and I'd love to play all
of them here but we really got to work
our way to the the the the Nazis that
want to take power now the one story
yesterday that I think everyone kind of
skipped over
and I think we should encourage this
again like I was saying in the a block
in the first 30 minutes that this is
this is a horrible thing for the
Republican National Committee
and it's a great thing for democracy
that Mike Lindell okay my fellow guy you
you think this [ __ ] this [ __ ] box we
just looked at was crazy in Maricopa
County doesn't hold a [ __ ] candle to
Mike Lindell Mike Lindell is nuttier
than a bag of squirrel turds now listen
to what he announces here on Steve
bannon's Trader TV listen to this this
is fantastic there's no there's nobody I
think in this country
that's a bigger supporter of President
Trump than Mike Lindell and has put his
money where his mouth is and his
companies where his mouth is and his
whole person and being if president
Trump was to call you up today after
seeing this and say hey Mike I saw it I
know you I'd love you you're fantastic
you're a great Patriot but I think you
ought to sit this one out uh for the
good of the RNC and the for good of my
candidacy in 2024. what would you say
sir
I would say I'm sorry sir but my
decisions already been made and uh and
uh I prayed about it and this is God's
Will and this is what I'm doing and uh
I'm not I've as I've been I think I've
been straightforward with everyone in
this country okay I apologize I thought
that was the clip where he announces
this is obviously the one where he
doubles down on the end
I really want to know and I'm just going
to quickly go on to anti-Semitism first
I'm just going to bring this topic up
just briefly because I'm sure we're
going to talk about it oh we're going to
get we're going to get to the Nazis at
the temple the people like Mike Lindell
and Kanye West and all these other
people want to talk about oh it's God's
will God was the one that told me to do
this he told me to run he said I should
be present I said don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever
but in that same breath
they want to say well if something bad
happens it's not God it's a bunch of
Jewish people that did it
and it may it's just like it every
single time you know it's like someone's
like well if something bad happened it
was Satan but something good happened it
was God it was God's will you goddamn
right
I'm just like Jesus Christ man like how
how did we get to this point anyway
we'll continue with Michael and Dale and
it's crazy what do you think about this
chucklehead being the head of the
Republican party I'm all for it I think
I think he can drive the Republican
Party in the ground quicker than Elon
Musk drove Twitter into the ground to be
quite honest with you
I'll be honest with you I think it's a
win-win situation Ronan McDaniel Ronald
Romney McDaniel is the worst damn leader
the GOP has ever had I mean think back
when think about I'm old enough to
remember when Michael Steele ran things
for the GOP yeah
they
set up Pennsylvania for Trump to win God
damn it and they wouldn't [ __ ] donate
to the GOP the these [ __ ] old racist
bastards would not donate to the GOP and
Mike still was out [ __ ] winning for
him but because he was black they would
not donate to the GOP so they had to
replace him because their fundraising
was dying
foreign
ER Romney McDaniel who has [ __ ]
failed in every election since she's
held the office and now she sucks so bad
the [ __ ] my pillow guy
might actually take her job well let's
let's watch how how do we lose here how
do we lose here I don't I don't know I
I'm again I don't know if we set up a
GoFundMe a Super PAC to run him as the
uh the national chair I'm all for
um Democrats and pro-democracy people
making sure this guy gets elected as the
Republican National chair I I'm all for
it let's listen to his announcement here
it's crazy too this here is to is uh 100
all in I've seen a big the RNC is one of
the most important organizations in our
country and it's not the ship is going
down and it's you know it needs a leader
and it needs a business leader it needs
someone that knows how to fix things and
how to be proactive in moving forward
yes it does like a change in this
difference I put the footprint of our
country has drastically changed it it's
when all over the board things that
things that you thought that you could
always count on you can't count on
anymore you can't you know and uh so no
this is a hundred percent
um a need and believe me people came to
me and someone first sparked this these
were big donors and when the big donors
are gonna leave and when they are in C
when you have all its own members going
hey we want to
um your donors aren't given and uh and
your and your party is gonna crumble and
it would it's already you can't if they
don't have a plan of something different
coming in a different input you're going
to get the same output Steve so I say to
that you want you want to make this you
you want to succeed uh you get you get
me elected uh to the all these states
where you know one of those 168 people
that I'm gonna call each and every one
of them and ask them what the problems
are and tell them Mama to fix it
um it's gonna be a uniting it's going to
be a great uniting of our country this
is fantastic nothing could be better
than that and he's not wrong though but
he's not wrong they don't Farmers really
are leaving the GOP they really are
absolutely they are leaving the GOP
because they [ __ ] suck man they're
shitty people and big corporations don't
want their name tied to the [ __ ] GOP
they don't they don't want to be married
to that that
[ __ ] disgusting [ __ ] box of an
organization they don't
but like I said before like like like
dumb [ __ ] prosecutor that's you know
can't wrap his head around that he's the
[ __ ] problem
Mike Lindell wants to double down and I
like how do we lose here there is no way
for us to lose democracy I think
democracy wins both ways here oh yeah I
mean look if the guy can run five
businesses up from just one cell phone
okay that was you know taken by the FBI
in a heart attack
uh then I know 100 that this man is the
perfect man you know hand to God that
can run the RNC into the ground right
this guy I love the claim he's like oh
man these donors came to me or these
people can't nobody [ __ ] came to Mike
Lindell okay nobody came begging to Mike
Lindell said you are the answer
yes he is true and Texas Paul called it
out again
GOP Mega donors are ditching Trump right
you've got people looking at or DeSantis
you got people looking at Junkin they're
all trying to figure out who to put
their money with right you've got the
GOP is losing young evangelicals okay
that is a [ __ ] key demographic for
them and if those people are leaving
you're [ __ ] because the older
generation while they still might stay
good they're about to be DOA okay the
next election the [ __ ] Dead on
Arrival okay and they're gonna be the
ones to be using dead people as voters
but when you look at this whole thing no
one is going to Mike Lindell okay he is
completely projecting out of his ass he
had some sort of dream hallucinogen like
state where he said oh yes God and that
lion behind me in the painting came to
me gave me that certificate of
excellence that's on the shelf right
there and said you Mike Lindell you are
the solution no one [ __ ] did that no
one came to him and yes he is right he
will call every one of those 184
whatever the [ __ ] number he gave he
will he will just continue to whine and
complain and call them where some of
them might need a restraining order
because the amount of harassment he will
give them to beg he will grovel and beg
on his knees to get some sort of vote
and someone be like oh sure you know
what kid I'll give you five bucks for
the candy bar but at the end of the day
No One's Gonna actually support him for
this position or at least definitely not
a majority I mean Mike uh
Kevin McCarthy might have a better
chance of running this position than
Michael and Dell but that's the insane
amount of craziness in this party and I
say [ __ ] go for it I want to see them
[ __ ] burn this [ __ ] to the
ground well I don't know if anyone knows
this and I forgot to play this part of
the clip where there's a promo code for
my slippers
um did you know Texas Paul that he sells
his slippers for like 119 or some [ __ ]
are you okay are they 119 and then
they're wrong they are of course if you
use the promo code I'm a [ __ ] idiot
you can get them for an app off or some
[ __ ] how in the [ __ ] literally this guy
now
I Gotta Give Mike Lindell credit he
spent a [ __ ] ton of his [ __ ] wealth
and the guy made a ton of money off
snaking away people's [ __ ] life
savings for pillows and blankets that
are just absolute garbage right just
absolute garbage because he he
advertised on talk radio that's how he
[ __ ] made his millions but I'll say
one thing that Mike Lindell
the thing that makes me want him to have
to be the chairman of the Republican
National Committee more than anything is
literally Steve band and Donald Trump
and the rest of them have been using his
money to push the big lie for two
[ __ ] years like Mike Lindell has went
almost [ __ ] broke for the sake of
Steve Bannon and Donald Trump like
literally he is one of the biggest
donors because he just can't stop lying
guy might even go and [ __ ] federal
prison depending on what happens to the
the case in Colorado with these [ __ ]
machines where he was encouraging that
County official to go [ __ ] tamper
with him and give him the [ __ ]
machines and [ __ ] who knows what the
hell comes of that and his cell phone
but I'll tell you
that nothing would please me more than
to watch every single time
um
Mike Lindell gets on Trader TV as and
the the the Chiron says Republican
National chairman and then he gives a
promo code for his slippers to make sure
that the Republican National Committee
can stay afloat because that's the only
way that they'll stay afloat is with his
[ __ ] slipper money this is ridiculous
but this is the Republican party what
the hell are we supposed to do Texas
Paul
uh eat popcorn
drink beer and watch I mean it's just
and you and and you know I can't help
but think about Elin when I think about
Mike Lindell right Elon Musk has two
other companies that require management
I mean Tesla is [ __ ] I mean Tesla is
completely [ __ ] all of China China is
hitting the market this year with a
couple really good EVS
every every other company that the um
the Germans BMW Merc they are pumping
Audi they are pumping out great electric
vehicles
Chevrolet here in this market is gonna
it has a whole line of electric vehicles
that are supposed to be top-notch
and that's exactly where I'm going
Chevrolet Ford the Ford Lightning is
super popular Chevy's coming out with a
new electric truck nobody's looking at
that piece of [ __ ] Lego looking
[ __ ] that that Elin put out
nobody you can get a really good looking
pickup truck electric you want one that
looks like an F-150 you want an F-150
that looks like one it it appears to be
an F-150 when you get in it it feels
like an F-150 why do you think F-150s
are so [ __ ] popular Elon because the
people like the way they look they like
the way they feel well you would you
would think that somebody who is like
you know got [ __ ] for caffeine free
Diet Cokes and some guns next to his
bedside table who is pew pew you know
like [ __ ] Second Amendment you would
think that somebody who is so patriotic
and so deeply rooted in the First
Amendment and what we believe and how we
need to fight tyranny that he would
understand the draw in a appeal of a big
[ __ ] truck right like they get that
demographic and it goes but you know
what we need we need this [ __ ] you
know Lego truck as Texas Paul put it
that I can throw a piece of metal at and
I'll break the window on stage and we
haven't heard anything about it lately
right I mean well he's gonna make a new
phone too Texas Paul he's got a new
phone he's gonna be out of the App Store
I mean this goes on and on I think this
is where you're going right but but the
point was you know starlink needs
management
Tesla desperately needs management right
now they don't need Elon musk's
reputation in the [ __ ] sewer right
now they really don't because that's the
only thing that's going to pull Tesla
through they're [ __ ] I would not own
Tesla stock right now for anything I
would be selling out of my Tesla as
quietly and quickly as I possibly
[ __ ] could right now because they are
[ __ ] this year the VW Buzz have you
seen this thing the ID bus from VW oh
the new one that is yeah that is the
give me give me a link a [ __ ] Tesla
well what I'm telling you what is this
new bug what's this what's this the ID
Buzz man you're gonna love it when you
pull it up I'm telling you I'm buying
one I am buying one I've been waiting
first model year goes through gets the
bugs out I'm buying the second model
year ID buds I'm telling you it's
freaking the coolest [ __ ] you're gonna
love it when you see it but anyways this
is
yeah this is what
Elon Musk is facing and he's fiddle
[ __ ] around on Twitter
he's fiddle [ __ ] around on Twitter
you know these people are lunatics
they're [ __ ] insane
they are yeah that's the ID buzz it
comes in turquoise it comes in Orange it
comes in I mean it's just cool as [ __ ]
man I've been watching YouTube videos on
this thing I love this this is what Elon
Musk is facing for competition and he's
out [ __ ] jerking off over Twitter
pissing off every [ __ ] Advertiser he
has
did I see that there was a penis pump on
his bedside table is that did I see that
I mean I don't know I would imagine
somebody hadn't photoshopped that in
somebody had to photoshop unless it's
been policy was fitting the barrel of
the gun
that way unless that's what you're
thinking I have no idea
thank you for catching that I was going
[ __ ] nuts and didn't want to have to
be the goddamn hillbilly to bring that
[ __ ] up when you put a gun on your
nightstand the barrel faces away from
you you [ __ ] [ __ ] do we really do we
really let me lay the gun on the table
with the barrel face me in case the guy
that comes in when I'm dead [ __ ]
asleep yeah but you know you don't want
him to have to turn the gun around to
shoot me
I mean this is natural selection we're
talking about here I mean that's you
know he's a genius genius genius genius
genius he is like since so since
September like beginning of September
when the deal was like all right you
really have to commit to this and you
got to finalize the financing all that
stuff and the court the judge was like
all right you really have to go forward
with this
since September Tesla stock is down 41
percent okay
41 September of this year right
September of this year this year in two
months right he has dropped the stock
price I mean it was already overvalued
that's to begin with but he dropped the
price 40 because of all the dumb [ __ ]
Antics he's pulling at [ __ ] Twitter
right the guy who says which is also
tied to this group because you're about
to show a photo of a guy who's a [ __ ]
pedophile and Elon Musk said his number
one priority is to reduce the amount of
child exploitation sexual abuse of
children on Twitter the guy just cut the
team in half
the guy that said it was the number one
priority which is save the children we
got to protect these kids Republicans
love children
in their beds oh they sure do and at the
end of the day [ __ ] pedophile
[ __ ] the guy that says he's
number one priorities to protect the
children and the abuse against children
on on Twitter just cut that team in half
so I would love to hear any of the
reasoning from the Republican side on
how that actually helps the situation
instead of puts more pressure and more
stress on a now reduced team that is
about less than 10 people oh well we got
a hot take here from Jeremy Johnson on
Facebook about economics this is
fantastic Jeremy Jeremy you really are a
fart smeller
um funding Twitter with Tesla you have
dude you literally that is what Texas
Paul is saying is why he wouldn't buy
Tesla stock because Elon has had to dump
his [ __ ] stock just to afford to do
this you dummy that is not how business
Works anyone knows and really honestly
the the craziest part about this whole
thing is there's billionaires all over
the world that are looking at Elon and
laughing at at him they're [ __ ]
laughing at him and the reason why is
because they he they are only raising
their stock he by plummeting his [ __ ]
wealth by bearing his [ __ ] wealth is
only [ __ ] raising their [ __ ] their
wealth and they know it they know it by
burning piles and piles and piles of
cash rather it's at Twitter or Tesla you
dumb [ __ ] Jeremy billionaires
are more excited about Elon Musk
destroying himself than destroying his
four [ __ ] companies because let's
face it that that [ __ ] that that
[ __ ] Welfare Queen wouldn't have
SpaceX or starlink if it wasn't for
[ __ ] government [ __ ] money our
[ __ ] money our [ __ ] money Jeremy
our [ __ ] money not his [ __ ] money
and by the way Twitter is funded by a
bunch of Saudis
so I mean if you're if you love if you
love Saudis Jeremy then maybe you do
love Elon Musk this is all [ __ ] dumb
again this has got to be a terrible time
to be a [ __ ] Fanboy it really does oh
yeah right right I mean
the if anyone remembers who Chris
Crocker is and the leave Britney Alone
meme oh okay they're crying right uh
that's exactly what the Elon stands are
right now they're complaining I mean
even Kevin McCarthy got out of the
meeting with Biden and and Mitch
McConnell and uh and Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi and some other people came
out of the meeting he was he the
question I think [ __ ] Ducey asked him
was how do you feel about Biden or the
government potentially looking into
Twitter right and he was like oh they
shouldn't be doing that blah blah Elon
is successful they should stop picking
on Elon Oh you mean like stop picking on
a private citizen about like like a
technology maybe like a lab cap or
something like that exactly you know
maybe maybe that would be a good idea
um so they're all [ __ ] Nazis let's
face it this is just this is just more
of the Nazi [ __ ] that's what this on
stuff is everyone says he you know he's
letting Nazis back on Twitter it's a
[ __ ] Nazi Fest over there
um and you know I'm not gonna leave
Twitter because I I love fighting Nazis
to be quite honest with you I'm not
going to stop but you have to that's
what I that's that is what I'm here for
now speaking of Nazis
we know over the Thanksgiving holiday
there was a bunch of Nazis that went
down and and dined with the King Nazi
now they're making a world tour here
apparently because they showed up on 10
pools and I don't know if you know Tim
Poole is uh or not he's the guy here in
the [ __ ] beanie as always because
he's bold and he's not like Elon where
he can afford
um actual gender uh affirming surgery
like getting hair uh hair plants put in
um which is gender affirming surgery by
the way just for you right Wingers you
don't know but if you look in the photo
you can also see this guy sitting here
it's Kanye West and then uh this guy
back here he's a Nazi that's Nick
Fuentes he is a Nazi he's I mean I I
would agree he's a white supremacists
he's a white nationalist but that
doesn't even begin to describe him he is
a Nazi and then this guy up front I
don't know if you know who this guy is
this is Milo my little [ __ ] Annapolis
oh my God he's a he's a uh uh hey hey uh
Hey fake Gabe and Jeremy Johnson this is
a guy you should really really be
simping for you would love this guy he
loves little boys by the way I don't
know if you've ever went and done it or
watched interviews about him he loves
little boys and he loves Trump and he
loves Marjorie Taylor green he loves
Republicans I mean he's quite the Nazi
sympathizer and quite the Nazi you know
um a helper here
um but Tim Poole did this show and they
streamed it on YouTube a lot of people
were pissed off that they streamed on
YouTube and frankly I'm happy they
streamed it on YouTube and the reason
why we get to [ __ ] we get to show
what these people are saying what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] it I watched I I you
watched the whole thing yeah I watched
uh pretty much the whole thing
uh to close to two hours I want to say
holy [ __ ] so here's here's what happened
all right just just set up context
so Kanye was there with Milo and Nick
right and this other guy
um I think his name is Dave I forget uh
it's another comment just just a white
dude yeah anyway so so I guess there was
a pre-show like talk right they were
like hey this is what we're gonna talk
about we're gonna bring up obviously
this dinner every once in once know
about this because it's a pretty big
news story right uh and then you know
Kanye was like I want to talk about
you know obviously a24 great cool we'll
talk about that
it's all recorded this is all recorded
no no this person is recorded but this
is this is Tim pool then after what
happened this is like the prep work
that's like yeah yeah but the reason I
know about this and everyone else knows
about this is because that Tim Poole
disgusted because this is what went down
so they're talking they introduce
everyone it's uh you know like Milo was
on the show last week I guess and Nick
Fuentes comes on the show this week and
with Kanye and they're all introducing
who they are you know kind of that
moment then they jump into big news you
guys had dinner at uh at Mar-A-Lago with
Trump how did that come about so then
they explained the the connection be
like oh well I got Kanye got connected
with Milo because I wasn't on Twitter
and someone from Alex Jones's team said
that they wanted to connect they oh even
better so they got connected that way
and then Milo was like oh the voice of
the new generation
smart man political commentary is Nick
Fuentes we should we should bring him
you should meet this guy so all three
meet and they say awesome we are
geniuses we know exactly what's going on
we need to actually make this a reality
which by the way Kanye West or yay
has not
filed any [ __ ] paperwork okay it's
all just talk he hasn't filed anything
is there anything but talk with these
[ __ ] really though right so
they go into the they go into the
conversation they ask them about this
they start to talk about how the
background gets set up that way then
he's like okay great so like what
happened to this dinner
and did not even get an answer because
this is where it went it
surprise surprise it went into
anti-Semitism so Kanye you mean they
jump straight to Jewish media you mean
that well this is what happened so that
so yay went in to talk about how uh just
this morning yesterday morning he found
out that they were trying uh they were
trying to kill him right there's like oh
I found out they're trying to kill me
and they're trying to take my money away
and hey is this Jewish people
because this is this clip they're saying
they they and they try to get right so
this is this is that explanation and so
how it leads up to this is yay keeps
talking about oh I wanted to start a
bank and it would cost me 70 million to
75 million and then I was trying to get
Diddy's ID or some [ __ ] like I mean so
instead start your own bank or something
yeah they're like start your own bank
you know and so he's like I want to
start this whole thing he's like I
walked into Chase and I was looking for
you know the CEO and I was like knocking
on the table like here's 140 million
dollars can I get a meeting he couldn't
get a meeting then he also it's it's CR
it's banana so then he also talked about
how his his trainer like his like
fitness trainer who trains like uh lizzo
and some other people is a Canadian a
former psyop I don't know the history on
this guy but they said he's a former
Canadian psyop like did MK Ultra worked
in the military [ __ ] that type of
[ __ ] and they and this is where it was
like oh this kind of sounds like
conspiracy territory because it is he
was saying how this guy
has been used to like uh manipulate and
you know uh
you know uh groom will say groom people
they like that word yeah they love that
word
then they go again does not even get
into the White House thing he just goes
on this whole thing about how they
Jewish people are the ones that are you
know oppressing him and they're taking
away his his wealth and again one of
those moments where he says oh God has
humbled me uh I did this because of God
but they Jewish people are the problem
and that's what he keeps saying right
and Tim Poole says he doesn't okay he's
like everyone's like oh Tim pull
challenged him Tim pool challenged him
Tim pool did not challenge him Tim Poole
just voiced his opinion and he's like
look if you're going to group of people
which I was like oh my God I can't
believe I'm agreeing with Tim Poole here
he goes if you're going to group a peep
a bunch of people and generalize them
and say that they are doing something
then that's a problem right he's like I
have Jewish people who work here but
they're not directly impacting Kanye
West's fortune or or situation right
so it's this it was crazy he doubles
down on let's let's watch this clip here
this is part of it the back and forth uh
between Tim pool because I think this is
the part where Kanye he actually gets up
and walks out yeah yeah and I'll tell
you what happened after a big thing is
like Trump had no idea who Nick Fuentes
was
and but this whole I just I just gotta
go right to the heart of this
anti-semite claim that's happening this
is something if you read the definition
it it says you can't claim that
there's multiple people inside of banks
or in Media
that are all Jewish or you're
anti-semitic and that's the truth
like it's the truth what are we talking
about and what library what do you mean
you mean
I'm saying like I've been labeled
anti-semite right so he he is by the way
he is an anti-semite I don't I don't
want to I don't want to skip over that
he definitely is an anti-semite and
you'll know by his words here
there's there's different beliefs about
our our Bloodlines you know like the
documentary that Kyrie posted and in
general America
has been left ignorant and history has
been changed so when we start
questioning things that question the
indoctrination
then you immediately get
you know
um
you said debanked or D what did you say
happened to you or demonetized the
platformed yeah demonized demonetized
okay they're on YouTube right now as
well when they're doing this they're on
YouTube they're not deep platform
they're not well the quick context so
the guy that I was mentioning I was like
oh this random white guy that guy who
says Epstein didn't Epstein himself
t-shirt right because he made a thing
about it in the beginning of the show he
was like Hey I'm so and so and I was
demonetized from YouTube so he had a
YouTube Drive I think he still does but
YouTube demonetized him so then he
started a t-shirt company and an example
was the one that he was wearing so they
had this discussion in the beginning
because he was talking about how he was
demonetized so that's what that's in
reference to but yes they are on YouTube
uh and I don't know if they're monetized
at all but I know that Tim pool
obviously has his private like become a
member and you get the yeah yeah but the
thing is is that it's not de-platformed
right if you're on the [ __ ] platform
you're you're on the [ __ ] platform
intent pool
you got we got to be clear here do you
you practically have to murder a baby on
YouTube to get demonetized I mean it is
[ __ ] hard
to get demonetized from YouTube I mean
you've got to say some vile [ __ ] man I
mean it's not like I mean [ __ ] I'm
demonetized is it I'm I'm demonetized I
guess I say some file [ __ ] I mean I'm
not people anymore I'm not de-platformed
they ain't kicking me off they might
today because of the [ __ ] I'm at my my
thumbnail it says what'd it say YouTube
Nazis and that was yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] YouTube could kick me off I don't
give a [ __ ] the thing is is that these
people who claim to be for free speech
who say oh we're being deep you people
are intentionally trying to get the
platforms so you can say this stupid
[ __ ] you don't care if they care that
they were D platform they wouldn't have
[ __ ] Nazis on their goddamn show they
wouldn't have Nick Fuentes they wouldn't
have [ __ ] mild Annapolis they
wouldn't have Kanye West on their show
if they were [ __ ] worried about
getting demonetized like today we're
playing these clips and they may
demonetize this or deep Platformers or
give us a strike or whatever because
we're showing these clips I don't give a
[ __ ] whatever you want to do I'm gonna
do what I want to do if you want free
speech then you gotta then you gotta be
willing to live with the [ __ ]
consequences you got to be willing to
live with it and they're not paying for
any consequences by the way they're not
paying for any consequences here they're
continuing to actually amplify and Tim
Pooh is doing them a favor now the best
part about these clips and I think it's
coming up here soon is when Tim Poole
who is a who is a a fighter for freedom
of speech and cancer against cancer
culture he won't say he literally will
not say on his show into a microphone
Jewish Banks and Jewish media he won't
do it he refuses to do it to say those
words and they're just words Tim they're
just words and he won't say it but let's
uh let me continue here on this clip and
we'll get to that one I think it's a
different one maybe and what's so
beautiful about this time is
everyone got to see
what's really been happening
and now we can really understand we can
see that Ronnie Manuel was right next to
Obama and then Jared Kushner was right
next to Trump
but so you
can do it I guess right I was hoping to
go for the news first nope not gonna go
for the news just like Gabe said so so
Texas Paul now they're blaming now
they're blaming the Obama presidency and
not only Obama presidency but the Trump
presidency on Jewish people being Rahm
Emanuel and Jared Kushner this is
absolutely batshit crazy right oh yeah
man and I did a video the other day on
the Seatac Airport guy oh yeah yeah and
man I tell you what he [ __ ] hates
Trump he hates Trump because there's
this subset within the right wing
movement that has said that oh no well
Trump's tied to the Jews I'm not even
kidding man no I agree this guy's one of
the vice there's a Vice news documentary
where one of these chuckleheads goes on
and on about that they're like well he's
just our starting vehicle because he's
technically a Jew Jewish sympathizer so
we don't want him to be a long-term
because his daughter is a convert Jew
and his grandchildren are Jews he
actually says that in like a vice
documentary
um and that was that was back after
2016. this wasn't yesterday this has
been a long time coming so you're saying
you're saying the guy in the airport
because I played that video yesterday
you're saying that guy is is anti-trump
oh yeah I got tweets from him where I
did my video that dude he just rails
against Trump man he [ __ ] hates Trump
he's a I mean he just
that guy is he
he is so goddamn racist that anybody
that's even like eating matzo ball soup
this guy [ __ ] hates him man I mean
and and you've got a I always break it
down folks just to remind people why do
these people hate Jewish people
why do they hate Hispanic people it's
always the same type of culture Jewish
the Jewish culture and Hispanic culture
are very similar very tight-knit
families very hard-working Pride
themselves on hard work Pride themselves
on achievement now if you're the kind of
[ __ ] nut that that gets kicked out of
[ __ ] Thanksgiving in your family you
know your own family kicks you out
because you're so goddamn insane that's
pretty goddamn scary to you
that type of
you know Behavior you know looks like a
cabal against you no you're just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] nut and that's why they
hate these that's why they hate these
cultures
you know Kanye hates Jewish people
because Jewish people are tight-knit
close people nobody wants to be
close-knit and tight with [ __ ] Kanye
nobody there wasn't enough cocaine in
the world to keep Kim Kardashian close
to him
I mean it
did I will say this so like you know
obviously in the in the yay 24
announcement video that he had right he
talks about how
uh and I don't know if this story is
true but if it is this is the only
moment we're like oh wow this is kind of
funny because it's it's Kanye uh just
totally trolling or [ __ ] with Trump
where Trump he was like I'm gonna run
for president and I want you Donald
Trump to be my vice president and then
he [ __ ] just like blew up and went
erratic and then talked I guess he
talked about Kim Kardashian sell his
random [ __ ] whatever
now assuming that story is true I'm like
wow this is great because this only
further fuels this implosion that is
about to happen right whether Trump
stays within the Republican party or he
walks across the street and becomes part
of the Independent party either way they
cannot figure out what path to take they
are so lost and confused right now
because they're all pointing figures at
fingers at random people they're blaming
you know you got Jesse Waters two weeks
ago blaming women were the cause that
they lost the vote you got them pointing
fingers at Jewish people because they
lost vote you got them point fingers at
Trump because he was the one that you
know wanted to go Roe v Wade and want to
go against this and this and that feels
like there's a pattern it feels like
there's a pattern here well they don't
ever want to look at themselves and say
oh maybe we're the problem yes maybe
it's us never will they will look in the
mirror and say oh yes I am the problem
well it's simple as trouble doing that
yeah he really does and honestly for a
guy who
I mean this guy spends a lot of money on
his on his Studio here why in the money
on beanies too well that's true but why
the [ __ ] can't he afford to get some
decent [ __ ] in the background I don't
know this is ridiculous the I don't know
what that is the samurai sword and I
don't know again I I can't understand
how this guy but anyways let's watch as
he he cucks here and and Tim Poole is
scared of words this is hilarious
especially coming from [ __ ] tem pool
of all people I don't use the word as
the as the way I guess you guys use I'm
sorry it is them though isn't it I mean
because because when you think about it
consider it
what do I mean like uh uh okay so how
about
are you leaving
are you afraid of the press
he's on
I'll say it right now
um
you got I I you guys want to bring that
stuff up
next question
you think EA's gonna come in here and
say Here's my opinion here's my
suffering I'm gonna say I hear you and
then he's gonna say and it was Jewish
people and I'm gonna be like okay but
don't you consider I'm not gonna do this
I refuse to make sure he's cool all
right go for it oh Milo's gotta go check
on yay okay so this is this is where it
all breaks down so so yay gets it and
sorry I said I said Dave earlier how far
is this and this is like 25 minutes in
okay
26 27 actually but they're like 25
minutes in also I I misspoke I said the
guy's name was Dave it's actually Luke
is the guy that is even better yeah the
other white guy anyway so Kanye gets up
and he goes oh I'm [ __ ] out right he
does well it doesn't even say anything
he just like walks up grabs headphones
leaves
and Temple's like well again he was not
he did not challenge him he did he just
he just voiced his opinion right uh and
not even that really but he just kind of
said hey you use it this way and I don't
agree with that right now if you're
running for president
and Tim Paul went into this and I was
like [ __ ] man another time I agree with
Tim Poole within like the same [ __ ]
hour this is crazy Tim Poole made a
point damn it I know really I was like
what the [ __ ] bizarre world am I living
in right now but Tim Poole made a point
last night and it was valid he was like
look if you can't take criticism or you
can't take someone that says I don't
agree with what you think and I don't
see the world the way that you do
then how are you supposed to be
president right like what platform are
you running on if somebody says
something and you just get up and walk
away right so Nick Fuentes at some point
after Connie gets up he leaves too Milo
says I gotta go check out so does Nick
it Nick gets butt hurt
Nick just leaves you don't you don't
ever see him on camera again he just ups
and leaves right so he leaves the studio
then Milo says all right I gotta go
check on him boom they leave then
there's this other girl that comes in
later and says I just spoke to them they
got a car and they left so they just
pieced out so how long was the show
after they left like an hour like uh
like I I want to say was close to two
hours so let me just check the total
time yeah yeah so they stayed on because
they're like what the [ __ ] we I mean we
had this whole plan
um two hours and 11 minutes is how long
the total stream was right so they were
there for about 25 minutes on air before
Kanye got up and left right
after that they continued to talk about
this point which is a valid point
they're like look if you if you're gonna
say this [ __ ] and you're gonna say that
it's all these Jewish people causing
this problem
then when you're asked about it to
clarify or just give me an understanding
of what you mean by it to be like show
me some evidence or show me why you
think this way and you get upset and you
get butt hurt and you leave then how are
you supposed to be in a position that's
a world leader right how are you
supposed to fix these problems if you
can't actually sit down and have a
conversation with someone that says I
don't agree with what you say now Tim
pool is a [ __ ] idiot and I don't like
him and he says I'm a Centrist [ __ ] that
[ __ ] the guy only attacks people on
the left supports right-wing ideologies
again he says he's just interested he's
disgusting piece of [ __ ] but Texas Paul
I want to show this clip because Gabe
actually talked about this clip earlier
this is why the Kanye West Milo
yiannopoulos and Nick Fuentes thing is
so important everyone's like why are we
still talking about this because because
they are the message leaders of the
Republican Party watch this [ __ ] right
this is this is right now he is the
minority leader in the House of
Representatives Kevin McCarthy he's
standing in front of the [ __ ] white
house in front of a microphone giving a
press conference after he's left the
meeting with the president of the United
States of America
okay this is what he had to say and this
is the questions that he is being
floated because the messaging is coming
from anti-semites and Nazis listen how
much has been wasted throughout but uh
I don't think anybody should be spending
any time with Nick Fuentes he has no
place in this Republican party I think
president Trump uh came out four times
and uh condemned him and didn't know who
he was well he just said he didn't know
who he was he didn't condemn foreign
Texas Paul he's a coward that's just
pure and simple right
yeah he is he's just he really is and
you know it's
it just it I it just gets stuck in my
crawl when I see this [ __ ] because I I
don't know it's just in my DNA it just
[ __ ] bothers me man
no Jewish person hurt Kanye West
ever you know who [ __ ] Kanye West
Candace Owens Candace Owens stuck it up
in Kanye West and broke it off
her husband George farmer
[ __ ] raped Kanye West selling him
partner
yeah I know that they had the deal I
don't know it was supposed to It's
supposed to close by the end of the year
but like it's something where I'm like
ah I don't know
who else is gonna do
you know us who's who's [ __ ] Kanye
West is the best is the Black Hebrew is
or Israelites he is buying repeating
their [ __ ] mantras over and over and
over [ __ ] over again and the worst
thing that can happen to that whole
movement is daylight
I mean when you're [ __ ] crazy the
worst thing that can happen to you is
people see you're crazy that you know
you're not in some [ __ ] obscure
Corner mugging people for their money
I mean you know just con and people like
Donald Trump that's the worst thing that
ever happened to Donald Trump was he got
put in the [ __ ] spotlight
you know that it's his own [ __ ]
personality that's killing him
another person that's really um hurting
Kanye here is Milo yiannopoulos
absolutely this is this is a post from a
while back on gab uh if anyone doesn't
know gab is just another [ __ ]
right-wing version of like telegram or
true social is just just a sewer that
that Twitter's starting to turn into
this is what Milo said
um Nick and Yi didn't discredit Trump's
oh no this this is this is him after I
got the wrong one yeah yeah I think what
you're thinking of is you're thinking of
all the this is this is after the the
dinner happened yeah you're referring to
the ones from 2020.
um there's there's a statement from 2020
where Milo is attacking Kanye
um brutal brutal attacks on Kanye most
of it [ __ ] delusional wise which most
things that Milo yiannopoulos say is
delusionalized that's why he went and
ran or helped run Marjorie Taylor
Green's campaign and it's the reason why
you're gonna see him
didn't she didn't she get him a
staffer's job yeah he was actually
working on the [ __ ] Hill I mean that
cockroach brought that other [ __ ]
cockroach into the halls of Congress
well that is possible the other thing
that's weird about Milo yiannopoulos is
he's been known uh to say out loud in
the microphones that he likes to have
sex with young boys
and the craziest thing too is how like
you've also got the Q Anon Laura Loomer
right oh man and that's got a whole
nother conspiracy theory that that this
is to take down Trump which honestly to
be honest with you guys I we gave me and
you've been talking about Nick Fuentes
for over a year yeah and I I've been
pounding the messaging that this guy is
the Republican messenger he's the one
that's that's that's forming their
messaging and we need to tie every
single Republican to this [ __ ]
I've been saying that for a long time
and Donald Trump did it in a matter of
moments when he let Nick Fuentes sit at
that table because again I'll say it a
thousand times if there's a Nazi sitting
at the table and there's 10 people
dining with him you got 11 [ __ ] Nazis
at that table there's 11 [ __ ] Nazis
you Temple you got this [ __ ] on
your show you're a [ __ ] Nazi
especially if you're not rebuking him in
every at every turn is this the uh and
how cowardly are the GOP over this how
[ __ ] cowardly this is the exit ramp
they're gonna try and take
really of everything that [ __ ] Donald
Trump's done
breaking bread with Nick Fuentes is
you're too much oh give me a [ __ ]
break well also you got to remember so I
mean just based on what we've heard
right and and this was the closest
opportunity that we were gonna get and
I'll give more context into what they
talked about after on the show because
it gives you an idea of how desperate
those three people are but basically
the fact that you know they're like oh
yeah over the weekend they played
[ __ ] they were trying to put out the
fires and play like PR control right
because the damage control because what
happened you mean Republicans are well
well Trump's Trump's group right
Republicans because Republicans you had
Ben Shapiro wouldn't say
that Donald Trump was dining with I
wouldn't say his name
you know how you don't dine with the
vile races and anti-semite well you
don't die it's like just say who did it
you've got also Ronald McDaniel right
who says oh well uh we condemn this
stuff it's not good won't say the names
right same stupid [ __ ] Kevin McCarthy
just did it's not Trump all these people
will not blame Trump so it's funny how
much of how many of the Republican Party
are ditching Trump but even the people
that are like I'm not gonna connect with
you for like we're gonna we're gonna
take a bit of a break here like for a
year we'll see how you are in a year but
right now what they're doing is they're
future proofing to be like well we
condemned the actions and the things
that Nick Fuentes says right and and
done right like the doj literally has
Nick Fuentes I'm not lying Google this
you can check you can fact check me
Jeremy Johnson and fake Gabe but at the
end of the day Nick Fuentes has been
labeled by the doj as a white
supremacist so you can go [ __ ]
yourselves you don't agree with me it's
literally the facts sorry facts over
here I was calling Shapiro Nazi
yesterday because he is yeah so look if
you
great you know he just won't he will not
they will not call Trump out by name
they will not say that he was supporting
a white supremacist or an anti-semite or
a racist he will not say that they go oh
well what's the what's the full context
here guys like what was the dinner
really over what like did they have a
Happy Meal or like what was the deal
and so you have them they will not
condemn them in a year let's see how it
how they come out and say oh yeah we
totally support Trump depending on how
the political climate is
but this is another thing where you've
got someone who is a [ __ ] Trump or Q
Anon person Laura Loomer coming out with
this idea that the reason
that Milo yiannopoulos is working
with Kanye is so that they're in cahoots
Milo and Marjorie Taylor green
to better Trump's chances it's yeah okay
well here's the thing here's Laura
loomer's little um
uh uh she posted this image of Milo's is
this his gab account is that what this
is uh I forget this is and if this is
real if this is real eight two twenty
two now Patriot takes post this so I'm
sure he checked on some of this but Milo
posted on 822 just not but a couple
months ago Kanye is gay don't make me
keep saying it which I mean I don't I
don't understand what the problem is if
Kanye is gay I don't understand why
that's a big deal now Milo says here
maybe this is his beef most rappers are
homos especially the new crop Jesus
Christ this is well understood in the
dot dot dot dot dot
now I got to jump in here for a second
go ahead yeah this is why I have not
pursued my rapping career
okay it's not it's not that most rappers
are homos that is not true that is not
true what is true is that you've got to
[ __ ] a Kardashian
and I ain't going down that road oh
Jesus Christ
we're definitely getting [ __ ] banned
now
and he goes on to say a bunch of racist
[ __ ] but Milo does in these yeah I'm
sorry and I I misspoke earlier basically
because I'm I was trying to uh find all
the telegram chats no sorry Laura Loomer
is accusing Margaret Taylor green of
doing this to undermine oh okay that's
what I was confused about yeah so you're
saying Marjorie Taylor green wants to be
the president of the United States and
Milo yiannopoulos and Kanye West and
Nick Fuentes which by the way all Nick
Fuentes and Milo yiannopoulos have
direct connections to Marjorie Taylor
green right and we all know that
Marjorie Taylor green is the cardboard
crotch Grabber of Donald Trump so she's
really close to him as well yeah I mean
that's the thing yeah here's Laura
Loomer this this she's the one that was
crying after she lost the election she
is off her [ __ ] rocker this is a one
crazy
crazy some [ __ ] I mean you think Carey
lake is crazy holy [ __ ] doesn't hold the
candle to Laura Loomer okay so she says
here in this is this on telegram or is
this on guests this is telegram okay so
this is her telegram account well well
well what do we have here does yay know
his campaign manager in quotes is going
to are going around lying accusing him
of being gay and literally threatening
to kill yay like I said Milo is just
trying to exploit ye for his money and
make Trump look bad take a look at these
archive posts and of course that's the
post we showed you which there's a lot
of them that are fun yeah and I just
want to let out a big well no [ __ ] right
yeah
it's it is I mean God damn dude this is
insane but what
what more satisfied than literally
literally and drawing between the
Republican party but it's the crazies
that are controlling their narrative
right yeah this is the greatest thing
ever this is why I want Mike Lindell to
be their chairman is because they can't
grab a hold of this Kevin McCarthy has
to stand in front of the [ __ ] white
house after he's had a meeting with the
president United States and answer the
question of why the guy who who got
[ __ ] kicked out of office by eight
million [ __ ] votes won't go the
[ __ ] way won't stop criming probably
gonna be indicted on several [ __ ]
charges in several different
jurisdictions why the [ __ ] does Kevin
McCarthy have to stand there and ask and
be asked the question oh who this
[ __ ] scumbag is having dinner with
the reason why is because they're the
leaders of their party that's [ __ ]
why these are Republicans that's who
they are that's who they [ __ ] are
they're [ __ ] Nazis and they're gonna
continue this [ __ ] and Kevin McCarthy's
gonna have to keep asking questions
unless he's not you know elected as a
speaker of the house which I guess
that's a I mean they they are they they
made their Nazi bed and they gotta sleep
in those Nazi sheets and they gotta they
gotta wrap themselves up because they
they did this to themselves
did you take Michael and Dale wait do
you think Mike Lindell sells Nazi sheets
I don't know for sure you know but if
you go back to like the Maricopa County
Board of Supervisors that whole meeting
was [ __ ] crazies they know I mean
they [ __ ] know that I mean he sat
there and said
these son [ __ ] he pulled his phone
out and said these some [ __ ] are
posting these comments in Twitter on
Twitter right now as we're having this
meeting he said they're saying the Lord
a supervisor gang yeah yeah he's talking
about these funny these people are
posting this they're on their phones
posting this [ __ ] right now because this
is what they want to show their people
they're not going to tell them the truth
but they're going to show these people
screaming saying ridiculous [ __ ]
and that's what they're all about I mean
that's what they're all about and the
people in [ __ ] Arizona are like now
could you please govern I mean could you
could you please just maybe do your job
right we elected you to do a job go
[ __ ] do it here's here's that clip of
him talking about this
I carry Lake War
28 28 posts on Twitter of 28 people
speaking with concerns and comments and
yelling at us but when it came down to
answering every one of those questions
now one tweet from Carrie Lake
explaining why there was the problems at
the polling side why there were some
lies not one explanation to the voters
it's a perfect example of Kerry Lake not
wanting to tell the voters the truth she
doesn't she wants to tell one side of
the story she posted 28 different tweets
I looked at it right now but not one
tweet once the public comment was done
that was it they shut it off and that's
all they want their supporters to know
they don't want to let the voters know
the truth and that's what's so
frustrating about this our elections
were safe secure accurate everyone had
the right to exercise the most
fundamental rate they have the right to
vote and when you have folks that are
throwing rocks at the system but not
wanting to tell the voters the truth
that's a conscionable shame on her shame
on her the voters spoke they decided it
just happened to not be her or some of
the other candidates it is what it is
the voters had the opportunity to have
their voices heard ballots were counted
and this election was safe secure and
accurate Mr chairman in my opinion the
2022 election is over
well there you have it there's that that
is the word from the Board of
Supervisors and of course the chairman
that he's referring to is a republican
by the way Bill Gates is his name not
related or not Microsoft Bill Gates
right yeah that guy you know I mean any
kind of [ __ ] they crazy
even before it was finalized and they
were counting right they were all
attacking Bill Gates I mean even in
even in that one Twitter space that we
were in at one point they were blaming
Bill Gates and mayor and Maricopa County
because the votes weren't counted quick
enough and it's like a gang you your
side is the reason why it takes so long
you are the ones that put these
protocols in place and made it slower
than it should be we all want these
votes counted immediately because we all
want to know exactly who won and who
lost and call it a day we don't have to
[ __ ] go so slow to get the [ __ ]
answer we all want this to be a quick
and and and an easy process for everyone
to follow through but when you've got
[ __ ] miss filter over here
complaining about how all the votes are
encountered fast enough and I don't
trust these people and this and that and
blah blah blah shut the [ __ ] up man
something else if you because Carrie
Lake was unwilling to accept the results
and still is unwilling to accept the
results but even before the election
when she was asked in various interviews
will you accept the outcome I'm gonna
and then she says I'm gonna win the
election and I will accept that outcome
and I will accept that result and I'm
gonna win and they're like well what if
you don't win she goes I'm gonna win the
election and I will accept that result
this is by definition the person who
says uh I'm taking my ball and I'm going
home they don't like the way that the
game was played because they started
losing and they wanted to pack
everything up and say well by default I
won because I don't trust what you guys
have to say right you know it's not even
like an incumbent this is a [ __ ]
newscaster that decided that she was
gonna go all in on Maga and turned out
that that was a [ __ ] up strategy to go
with you know I'm I'm I'm with Carrie
Lake here on the screen and with all
this talk about the election Nile and
the craziness and the squirrel turds
running around listen I'm going to
propose if Mike Lindell okay and Mike
Lindell could win the chairmanship that
would be fantastic but what if what if
we have Carey Lake as Kanye West running
8 and 2024 I'm just saying I'm just
trying to you know Advance the crazy
here well that literally that would
assume two big things one that Kanye had
actually submitted to run and two right
that Kerry Lake because Carrie Lakes big
dream here is she goes well it's either
me or Marjorie Taylor green and I feel
like Margaret Taylor Green's out of the
way when it comes to Vehicles maybe
Texas Bob Texas Paul maybe uh Carey Lake
hasn't grabbed the cardboard crotch as
many times as um as as Marjorie Taylor
green I I don't know I I think I think
Trump's favorite is Marge what do you
think well the only one thing I'll add
to that is uh you've got also Trump on
true social trying to push the idea of
deniers deniers but he cannot spell
deniers wrong or right right he's saying
dinos or whatever the [ __ ] it's called I
wouldn't be able to spell it either so
but the Texas Paul what do you think do
you think Marjorie Taylor green is uh
Trump's favorite over Carrie Lake what
do you think I think everybody is vastly
under underestimating where Trump's
going to come out of this he's going to
come out on top it won't be Ron DeSantis
and and and
he I if I had to pick a running mate for
him
um I'm gonna say it's not going to be
Marjorie Trader green it's not she her
her unfavorability numbers are way too
freaking High way too high she's not
even like within her own oh yeah oh yeah
Carrie Lakes liked within the party she
is Republicans love her let's listen
here because this is why this clip is
why they [ __ ] love her right here I
want you to know that I am firmly in
this fight with you where arizonans were
expected to wait in line two three four
even five hours simply to exercise their
sacred right to vote Arizona
America if we do not stand up and speak
up right now about the most dishonest
elections in the history of Arizona I
truly fear for our future I'm working
with the team a patriotic talented
lawyers on a legal case to challenge The
Botch elections my team and I realized
how important this case is and what is
at stake
yeah go ahead
okay those are not her [ __ ] voters
that had to stand in line that's just so
[ __ ] hypocritical about this you know
in bucks to kahoot of [ __ ] Arizona
where her voters are they voted
instantly they walked in handed an ID
and went and voted
she's actually bitching about Democratic
voters in Phoenix that had to wait in
line
not her voters
her voters [ __ ] sailed through and
Johnny got Rock's [ __ ] neighborhood
and Chad's [ __ ] neighborhood they had
plenty of polling places
on Chad he moved to Arizona
just making sure I didn't know I didn't
know where Evie was still but you know
exactly what I'm saying you know exactly
what I'm saying you go to [ __ ] Johnny
got Rock's neighborhood and that dude
didn't have to wait five [ __ ] minutes
to vote he didn't he did not
the person that had to wait is the
person in [ __ ] fee not Phoenix
[ __ ] Tucson all the all the
Democratic hubs where there are actually
people that love and get along with each
other they intentionally yanked out the
number of voting polling places out the
Republican [ __ ] douchey
they made it difficult for Democrats to
vote
period and she's sitting there like a
[ __ ] hypocrite pretending like oh
well people had to stand in line for
five hours well you [ __ ] did that but
Texas Paul that's what I'm saying that's
what I love about her the most that's
why that's why I believe what you're
saying I think Trump's going to get
indicted I don't I don't think he'll go
on trial till after this next election I
believe I believe what he's doing with
his presidential campaign is punting the
trial after the election he's going to
be indicted they're gonna they're gonna
run through he can he can kick that can
until after 2024 he's gonna run and he's
gonna [ __ ] lay waste to all these
idiots Kanye Nick Fuentes Milo uh anyone
DeSantis Kemp Hogan uh uh uh Junkin
whoever the [ __ ] stands in Trump's way
he will lay waste to them because there
is not a goddamn thing he won't say to
win and I believe you're right I believe
he's going to pick Carrie Lake
and I believe that this that you're
gonna see an electorate in this country
that is more sick of the crazy than they
have ever been before even after the
last two elections and I bet he loses by
almost 12 million votes I bet he loses
by 12 million or more and Carey lake is
going to help him get to that 12 million
with that kind of crazy but that's what
they [ __ ] love about her that's what
they love they love you we also have to
realize I mean like if Trump goes for
the hat-trick awesome right if he loses
three times in a row on the popular vote
[ __ ] him oh man beautiful but we do need
to remember that one by Trump running
for president again he has admitted that
he lost the 2020 election right that's
that's a win right there if Kerry Lake
then accepts this potential vice
president like uh running mate thing she
also has to accept that she lost the
2022 midterms another win and we know
based on what we've seen so far it's
like yes they're dumping Trump the gop's
pissed evangelicals are pissed nobody
wants to back this guy right now because
he's toxic right he's uh
he's he's a he's a waste of a candidate
because he's proven you know Paul Ryan
even came out of the [ __ ] woodwork
the other day on ABC and was like look
he's a loser I'm a never again Trumper
right like he he even though he was you
know this is a guy who's on Fox's board
by the way right this this former
speaker the house is on Fox News yeah
but guys
you can't dump that much stock at night
you really can't because they will
they'll they'll turn 180 degrees no
exactly and that's what I mean like
right now they're abandoning Trump I
mean because it the
the time like proximity of when the loss
came right this big loss for this Red
Wave was more like a trickle and then
Trump announcing thing and that he was
gonna somehow get out of this it's not
it's too close together if he had waited
he might have had a better kind of
welcoming party
but right now he's the only candidate
that's out there that's a nouns or has
officially submitted paperwork and
they're like well look you haven't won
before and at the end of the day you I
mean you've also got Bill Barr that says
like look I think there's enough
evidence to indict Trump but when the
question comes back and it says I'm
willing to vote for Trump because well
they all vote for him right the same way
they won't they'll you know they'll
they'll say that anti-Semitism is not
good it is very bad but they will not
call him out by name because again they
are future proofing
if and when Trump actually becomes the
party's nominee and they say great we we
fully support there's enough [ __ ]
whatever enthusiasm uh behind this guy
which you know might be inaccurate also
too they might be backing a candidate
who actually isn't representing or the
voice of these people right so that's
another thing that will probably
backfire them if and when they they go
and they actually say great Texas ball
Texas ball one more thing though and I
want to ask you about because I the
reason why I say 12 million votes is
because there's likely to be I think I I
forget the number but I think it's uh
likely gen Z voters that are going to be
coming in the next two years for the
2024 is going to be in the millions um
and we know more people are gonna you
know vote against crazy than they are
voting for crazy
um you think you think Trump's going to
be battling against Biden again is that
what you believe
yeah I actually do at this point I
really do I uh at this point there's no
way to look at look how quiet Ron
DeSantis is
I mean he is really he understands if he
goes to war with Trump he loses right he
does but he doesn't he wants he loses
the whole thing he loses exactly yeah
and that's why Trump came out you're
talking about why you know he jumped in
so early because he had to kneecap
DeSantis before he got any real momentum
he just did and everybody else is trying
to say okay well we're going to say
they're trying to pull this maneuver
we're going to get the stink of
Charlottesville we're going to get the
stink of all of that off of us by
throwing Nick Fuentes under the bus
who's [ __ ] nobody to us
that that's what they think they're
going to do they think they're going to
peel that [ __ ] off and we're going to
let them do are they we're not going to
let them do that because what Trump's
going to do and why I say Trump's going
to win is Trump's going to grab a hold
of Nick Fuentes here in a few days and
hug the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of him and he's
going to get every one of your [ __ ]
racist grandpas racist uncles all those
people are going to [ __ ] love Trump
again and that's it that is it because
he plays to the worst he takes the worst
of the Republican Party he holds it up
on a platform and he says this is who we
are and you're wonderful
because of it and nobody else has the
balls to do that and those [ __ ] will
follow him they'll lose because gen Z is
informed and motivated and and they
killed most their [ __ ] Memaw's off
with [ __ ] covid because they're
idiots I mean but you know and look at
the difference
well the other thing too is uh it's not
like you know because they're the people
that are like oh what's the point of
voting if I don't get this result that I
want and obviously like you've got
people that have that Vibe like
demoralizing defeatist kind of attitude
but when you've got a group of people
like gen Z who proved that if you come
up on with numbers and you and you push
behind a a a group an ID and a platform
um that is you know I don't know
anti-fascism crazy uh that you actually
can
help support democracy and fight this
this uh this overtaking of what we have
and they've seen that and it works and
they say great we know it works and
we're going to do it again right it's
not like ah we really tried but the
system [ __ ] us over it was like we did
it we tried and we pulled it off and now
2024 they're gonna be like great now I'm
gonna go get more people I got my
younger brother my younger sister
whatever they're coming up I got other
people I we know it worked before and
now we're going to double down
and expand the network that we have
coming in because now we've got people
who are patiently waiting to turn 18 so
they can vote I agree and Texas Paul I
think it's going to be a fight and we're
going to stay in this fight for the
whole two years we're going to lean into
this thing
um even though even though it seems like
Jesus we're not even done with the 2022
midterm yet but we're going to lean into
it we're going to keep fighting it tell
us how you're fighting over on your
YouTube channel give us a rundown before
we go
oh man men men
we're just we're just still popping them
out every Wednesday night you know we're
we're just doing it we're uh grinding
every every damn Wednesday we get
together about 9 30 Eastern time and pop
out is you know weekly events it's it's
it's Brando and I just sit back and
[ __ ] and have a good time I mean it
really is it's a laid-back show and
we'll go over to Texas Paul's YouTube
channel and check out
um check out Wednesdays at TNT Texas
Paul and Tennessee Brando go go check
out that YouTube channel and follow
Texas Paul everywhere you got a link
tree right uh oh yeah we'll put that in
the description here I don't think I
added it but I'll put it in the
description here when we get off the air
so everyone can go follow Texas Paul
linktree in his in his Twitter thanks
for joining us as every Tuesday we have
Texas poll here Gabe San Sanchez it's
good to have you back today as well
everybody remember noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch don't forget to hit that
subscribe button in case YouTube Kicks
us off and go follow us on all the
platforms Facebook Twitter as long as
it's still around help follow us on
Twitch and go download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google it's
over there we're not in a fight with uh
with apple like Elon is right now also
when you're over there downloading and
subscribing to the podcast make sure to
leave us a great review and go to
store.dtonymichaels.com get you a [ __ ]
em sticker I rarely show these get you a
[ __ ] em sticker stick that [ __ ] wherever
you want
um and go to
store.dtonymichaels.com and get you a
[ __ ] sticker same time same place
tomorrow everybody Surfside
[ __ ] we'll see you later Texas
ball have a good one
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
foreign